buenos días buenas tardes soy steve
hoffman y hoy voy a hacer un vídeo en
castellano en español voy a hablar de la
importancia del aprendizaje de idiomas
de ninguna manera
pasiva
lo que quiere decir basado sobre la
escucha y la lectura y porque este tipo
de aprendizaje es mejor de mi punto de
vista que el aprendizaje tradicional en
las escuelas o bien que es algo que se
debe hacer
aun si estamos estudiando en escuelas
que la lectura y la escucha
son las dos cosas más fundamentales más
importantes para
tener éxito en el aprendizaje de idiomas
y hay cinco razones que voy a explicar
esas cinco razones pero antes quiero hay
dos cosas que quiero decir
una cosa es que
con mi esposa voy a visitar a méxico
este no es un gran sombrero mexicano
pero
es un poco el estilo del países del sur
sur del américa del norte y pues
queremos visitar a méxico en el mes de
febrero
del fin del febrero al principio de
marzo 2 quizás tres semanas y vamos a
concentrarnos en el centro del país
porque méxico es un gran país
y tenemos la intención de pasar una
semana a la ciudad de méxico y después
con los autobuses porque me han dicho
que son muy muy cómodos auto carros que
podemos viajar del pacífico al atlántico
y también tenemos amigos que viven en
san miguel de allende
bueno parece que hay muchas cosas que
hay que ver entonces si hay amigos
mexicanos que pueden darnos algo
consejos este sería muy muy útil para mí
muchas gracias y la segunda cosa es que
quiero hacer una reunión en general a
google+ para toda la gente que habla
habla español
nativos u otros que quieren participar
podemos hablar hasta 10 personas al
mismo tiempo lo que quiere yo y 999
otros pero los otros puedes mirar y aún
pueden mandar cuestiones preguntas
pero tenemos que decidir el tiempo
porque hay yo creo que hay gente en
españa que querría en europa que quería
participar y también en nuestro
hemisferio o aquí en américa latina'
obvia en américa del norte
entonces dígame si tienes ganas de
participar y que es el tiempo más
condenables
de dos cosas que quería decir bueno
ahora el import best buy news learning
porque es importante de impuestos es
bueno es hay que hacer entrar las cosas
en la cabeza hay que habituarse al
idioma
y como yo siempre decía para el
aprendizaje de idiomas necesita necesita
es preciso tres cosas
la actitud de la pendiente que quiere
aprender tienes confianza
y te gusta idioma son las cosas de la
actitud de la pendiente segunda cosa es
el tiempo porque necesitas mucho tiempo
cada día durante meses y meses y meses y
la tercera cosa hay que darse cuenta de
lo que está ocurriendo
en el idioma ok pero para esas tres
cosas es muy importante que el cerebro
tiene bastante oportunidad
para para descubrir y el idioma y
acostumbrarse al idioma
crear bueno
conexiones
el cerebro y por eso qué
el aprendizaje pasado sobre el input es
muy bueno y hay cinco razones primera
razón porque es más efectivo en mi punto
de vista que el tiempo que vas a pasar
en la escuela en la escuela puede ser
muy importante pero no es suficiente no
es suficiente porque hay una escuela vas
a escuchar otros alumnos que no son
nativos y bueno es como útil a la
utilización del tiempo es menos efectivo
menos efectivo que en la escucha y la
lectura y es efectivo yo lo he hecho
muchas veces recientemente con el checo
en un año
aprendí súbitamente suficientemente de
checo para poder viajar a praga hablar
con la gente yo comprendo la radio puedo
leer y todo eso entonces esto hace 10
años
con sistemas por ejemplo si yo
hubieron hubiera
asistir a clase yo soy
cometido estoy cometido que no hubiera
logrado al mismo nivel
de cecco que
he hecho con el sistema de basados sobre
la lectura y la escucha y él
bueno el crecimiento del vocabulario
bueno es efectivo primero segundo es
fácil tu puedes hacerlo lo que quieres
tengo siempre conmigo mi ipod o en bici
para escuchar si tengo diez minutos aquí
cinco minutos allí voy a escuchar y voy
también leer porque tenemos con lynn
tenemos el link que también puedes
utilizar en el ipad ipad ipad tax lo que
sea léger puedes traer contigo cosas
para leer si estás en el autobús o lo
que sea entonces es muy fácil tercera
cosa cuando hablas puede puedes hacer
errores pero escuchando leyendo no hay
cosas que no comprendes quizás fueron
escuchando escuchando poco a poco
comprendes más pero no es un error no
hay presión no hay tensión es fácil
y no puedes cometer cometer errores
entonces no hay tensión
cuarto razón es barato puedes estar
cosas a la biblioteca puedes buscar
cosas en el internet muchas cosas que
son gratuitos como por ejemplo todos los
recursos
la rayo que yo he encontrado por el ruso
por el chaco es que hay también en todos
los idiomas puedes utilizar el link que
no es muy caro
puedes utilizar link gratuitamente
también por ejemplo como hacen la
mayoría de la gente
entonces es barato
y quinta razón es que es interesante si
puedes leer sobre cosas que te interesan
porque los libros clásicos para aprender
idiomas son muy aburridos muy aburridos
sobre temas que no soy que yo no he
escogido escogido pero con el checo por
ejemplo después de 22 meses he buscado
cosas sobre la historia
llegué a check
la república checa sobre la política
sobre todo todas las cosas así también
con el ruso conozco un montón de cosas
sobre la vida en rusia y todo a través
de la lectura y la escucha con podcast
con estaciones de radio que tienen
recursos disponibles en disponibles al
internet etcétera entonces es efectivo
es fácil no tienes la posibilidad de
cometer errores es barato es interesante
es por eso que yo siempre digo siempre
digo
no es parece que bueno si hay gente que
no pueden estudiar independiente
independientemente entonces van a la
escuela pero también si tú estás
estudiando a una escuela tienes que
pasar la mayoría de tu de tu tiempo
escuchando y leyendo y una vez que
tienes el base comprendes la comprensión
es tan importante cuando comprendes es
más fácil desarrollar esta capacidad de
hablar por ejemplo ahora que hace mucho
tiempo que no hablo español tengo bueno
un poco de dificultad para exprimir me
me pero en tres semanas e méxico
soy convencido que mi nivel de español
incluso los errores que cometo el nivel
va
mejorando se la cantidad de errores va
bajando sé
porque comprendo comprendo esto lo es lo
más importante
la república checo la búlgara también
cuando me fui a praga
y yo todo comprendí todo y hablando
mi nivel de cecco ha hablado y se mejora
cada día pero este pase es muy
importante y esté siempre a través de la
lectura que la escucha del import based
learning bueno ok
nos vemos en méxico adiós y muchas
gracias